- So wait your dad famously plays golf?
- Yes.
Are you into golf at all?
- I've played golf just
to spend time with him,
actually retired, actually
retired at a very early age
because there was one
time that he took me out,
um, we were up in Pebble Beach,
and you know I had my
own little set of clubs
and he tried to teach-
- Your first time to golf
was Pebble Beach?
- I know.
- Congratulations, I'm like wow!
- Thank you.
- Uh yeah, and so there was a little
course there and you know,
sometimes it's always
been Lopez versus Lopez,
like we kind of sometimes butt heads.
And you know I was getting annoyed,
he was just like trying
to teach me how to swing
and I was like, oh all right
you want to teach me how to
swing, ill show you how I swing.
And I just put all my might
in it and I got a hole in one.
(crowd claps)
I got a hole in one.
- You Happy Gilmored the situation.
- At like 11 years old.
And I just turned around and
you know I can't see the ball,
and my dads- all the blood
just came out of his face, he just
and people back there were like,
did she just shoot a hole in one?
My dad, was like, yeah
- Cause your,
- You know.
- Your, are you both emotions?
Your like angry and
proud (laughs) your like
- Well no I mean there's a second half
to the story where the
ball went in the hole,
and then Mayan some how got the
golf cart stuck on the rail,
so two wheels are moving but
none of them touch the ground.
(laughs)
so, it took her a little
longer to get back to celebrate
than we would have liked. (laughs)
because the golf cart
got stuck in the tracks
- She was done.
She Happy Gilmored it. (laughs)
- And she just missed it by that much
- Its all in the hips, you know (laughs)